so let's just go
let's go ahead shay so in malaysia over
there is 11 over here is nine
but we're right on time we're right on
time alhamdulillah
so tell us i'm going to take us back in
history again so we met
i believe it was correct me if i'm wrong
first time we met
that was uh in hajj and you gave me
something that i still use to this day
to show the mercy of islam
because you went and you went over the
letters i s-l-a-m
islam says love all mankind can you go
ahead and elaborate on that
yeah because when you say islam
i-s-l-a-m
you also can translate into i
is i as a shell
a is all l is
uh no l is love
a is all m is mankind so
i shall love all mankind
i-s-l-a-m
so that is what the prophet was sent for
um
allah said to us we now send you except
to bring the mercy to the world
to everybody not only to one race or
only to the muslim
but rahmatullah mean to the world
so this is very important now because of
the
the mercy the mercy is more than love
because having mercy meaning you are
prepared to go through all the pain
and suffering just to save others
to save the ummah to bring people from
darkness to light even
they are not ready to accept they go
against you
but because of the mercy you have you
keep on
praying for them you keep on inviting
them
and of course at the end of the day
allah says the one who give hidayah is
allah not us
i like what you mentioned about mercy
because we often get this
word thrown around he says to her she
says to him i love you baby
and all these empty slogans right but
there's no mercy between the two
just empty words but the mercy as you
said prophet muhammad was sent as a
mercy to all mankind so what would you
say to
the president of france now with all of
the
attacks that are happening against islam
what would you say to him
regarding this mercy of islam
yeah we as a muslim you know what's
obviously going on in france now right
yeah we are we are following this very
closely too
you see and then we always believe that
this is one
of the area that may be something the
muslim must reflect number one
whether we have been talking to all
these people about islam
especially muslim leaders i'm not
talking about the public when you talk
about president
you talk a politician so leader to
leader like our prophet
yeah when he was the leader of the ummah
he was addressing
the other leaders but today the muslim
leader
is so naive so weak you know they don't
even
present islam to other leaders
so they are very ignorant to me i will
say
they are ignorant when you are ignorant
sometimes you can be
arrogant so
it is just too bad but is awake
call for everybody you know this
is just something that allah is telling
us
again that we muslim wherever you
are you must set a good example you must
integrate
yeah with everybody so that show them
this is
islam islam is about unity islam is
about
love we don't care what color you are no
we all like our children of adam and all
children
adam we are like one big family and
allah created us different
race and nation or tribe is for us to
get to know one another
so when that one failed this thing can
happen this fitna
of course it is not wise for uh
for a leader a very intelligent person
a person who are so high above
yeah they should be very very careful
when they speak
when they talk about others
the leaders should unite people not to
create
unrest and hatred
so of course we are hurt as a muslim
we must feel hurt
because we we love our prophet more than
ourselves that's why
no they don't understand they just don't
understand there are people who say no
the muslim if you go and burn the quran
you go and talk about it they still you
know very patient when
you hit prophet muhammad samuel muslim
now the muslim is just have to wake up
how about the uh you mentioned leaders
was it
imran the one of the leaders from being
the president of pakistan
it seems like what do you think is he
taking up the call like he's uh
it seems like many are sleeping there
but what do you think about him have as
has he has he
tried to do uh some of this what you're
talking about at all
we hope that our leader will be very
proactive
so when a leader to a leader when they
talk to one another
it makes a lot of difference big
difference right
big difference so the leaders need to
step up and have some
have some courage to go ahead and share
this message
what do you think about the courage of
our brother habib who
been also kind of stepping up a little
bit and he spoke out against this and
this president and these attacks on the
prophet saw some have you heard of this
of habib uh no no
i don't think i follow everything no uh
closely
yeah yeah tell us for the people that
don't know
you actually you were formerly a
you were buddhist we did that program
before but you were actually you were
buddhist at one time right
yes yes of course and then you were you
officially i don't remember a monk
also not really a man but i
i am one of the good followers
and i don't reach the end there's the
level of a monk
you know but we are going towards that
tell us i remember you telling me uh the
story of guatemala buddha
about him about him possibly maybe even
being a prophet
i remember getting that from you can you
elaborate on that
yeah we know that our prophet sallallahu
alaihi mentioned there
many there are 120 over thousand of
prophet been sent
of course they are not is there's only
three 313 or 315 there is
a messenger and then only 25
is recorded in the quran but there are
many
that the name is not been known only
allah know best but
why we say that is not impossible
is because of the teaching every prophet
was sent
as bashiron one zero bashiran and nazar
to convey
glad tiding good news for those who
follow
and also to warn those who disbelieve
and those who reject and then if you
look in the teaching of guatemala
then you'll find that he will always end
with sukkah
in the sanskrit language
means glad tiding and warning
good news and bad news
and then you see that the the they have
you know the
one was the most important uh ingredient
in iman yeah that we muslim must
always be very strong
in that is to believe in god and qatar
the sixth the last article of faith
there is to believe in what is being
ordained what has been predestined by
almighty creator allah mean
and then when you look into the teaching
of guatemala then you come up with
the karma karma is
so of course we don't we cannot claim
100 percent because the name
is not been mentioned in the quran or in
the hadith
but we know that allah said the i have
stand to all nations
but the teaching never contradict
to my understanding yes yeah because you
you being a part of someone who was
actually a buddhist
then you actually ended up going above
and beyond you end up
really looking into islam you accepted
islam submission to the creator not the
creation
you accepted it and now comparing the
teachings there of the pure monotheism
how did how do you see then you became
an islamic scholar how do you see from
your
perspective that it evolved to where it
is today from
you talked about his life he was a
simple man
you know he kind of went away if i
remember from before
he was a prince and then suddenly he
came to realize
to see the reality of life because when
he was in the palace
they don't really show him all the the
real
uh the reality of life the suffering the
poor
the old age they want him to just see
everything that is beautiful
until one day when allah that he was
being
he was able to travel with his parents
out
from the palace and that is the time
allah subhanahu wa
opened the way that he managed to just
get out from the
main group and then he saw behind all
the beautiful
picture that's been displayed in front
of him he saw
how people is suffering the poor
the sick the old age then he start to
realize something is wrong
what i was being informed been exposed
in the palace been taught by my parents
and the people around me in the palace
is just
like a drama show the reality is
different
so al hamdulillah allah gave him the
awakening that's why you call
buddha buddha came from the root word of
bud
but means the awakening
so he think you see he is starting to
think he wants to
get out and like he wants to look for
the truth
he want to look for the answer
to what is life i'm living in the palace
with everything around me everybody is
smiling everybody is
good everybody is healthy but i now i
realize outside
the palace people are suffering people
are dying so that's why he make an
attempt to make a hijra he left
the palace and make his first hatred he
left
and that's where he was looking and
looking and he just
he found some people who was
doing a lot of meditation in the
wilderness but
the way they do
about what they are trying to do is it
didn't
attract him because it looks so dirty so
ugly not
clean what is this so he don't believe
that that should be the way
yeah to find god that shouldn't be the
way to get closer to god that shouldn't
be the way
so then he keep on searching no one can
guide him no one can give an
answer until he make a kalwa
and all prophets do kalwa prophet
muhammed
the prophet moses went up to the
mountain everybody
go for an isolation called kalwa
and there he was meditating under the
bull tree and that's where
he was given the enlightenment and
that's why after receiving the
enlightenment
then he start his mission he start his
call
and that is when he was named as
buddha because the word buddha means the
enlightened one
so the word enlightened to us is hidayah
so so now you connect these i mean uh
see what
translate the word again to uh awaken
what's the word awakening awakening
awakening good
good good so bud means awakening
so when you're awakening to the reality
of this dunya right this
life you can you can you can you can
really relate to the concept of islam
thinking like what's the purpose of life
why am i what am i living for where am i
going when i
die awaken to the reality that you're
going to die that this life is
transitory is short
that concept is there but how did it
evolve sheik how did it evolve to where
it is today where
we see people actually working
worshiping themselves
as a god worshiping buddha you know
worshiping the creation through this
yeah it's where we call man-made
religion
the cult comes in people start to make
money
and commercialize everything oh
commercialized business now became big
yeah
yeah yeah you me and i don't know you
can sell he's a good business
and trying to say no this is this is the
buddha that can help you like
happen in the time of abraham the father
other he is idol maker
you know and then he he is calling
people to sell
his his idol and then tell people to
worship this idol
is a big business so it happened to
every generation even the time of jesus
it happened jesus never called people to
worship him
neither buddha called anybody to worship
him
and you see they have they have
frustration
if you look at the buddhists when they
do their prayer they prostrate
a lot of chanting yeah so if you look at
that then you see that
there's a lot of similarity
a link with one to another
the only problem today is when people
start to
worship something they are starting to
make sure that everybody the later on
will follow the idea
and people the majority of the people
today they are blind followers
they don't really want to think they
don't even want to reflect they just
want to be a good follower if they
follow the right one
alhamdulillah the truth but majority are
not doing that
that's why in the quran the only book if
you go back if you compare the old
testament and the new testament in the
quran the last testament
allah keep on reminding us
no don't you think don't you reflect see
allah want us to have an
open mind don't do anything without
knowledge
in surah islam don't say or do anything
without knowledge
why because when you are a blind
follower then
you can easily be misguided by anybody
there's a beauty of islam you see
there's a beautiful
yes how i communicate with my own people
when i talk to them
when i talk to the people of the
christian i was a christian
to before then i talked to them and said
brother sisters
do you believe in jesus they say of
course
you cannot be a christian if you don't
believe in jesus good
now we cannot be a muslim if we don't
believe in jesus
i said can you be a christian if you
don't believe in the bible
he said no but once we believe in the
bible he asked me back
i said i don't know i'm asking you can
you be a christian
without believing in the bible i think
no
i think we should believe good we muslim
cannot be a muslim if we don't believe
in the injil
now i'm going i'm going now a bit
further do you believe in moses
and then they ask me why must i believe
in moses i don't know i just want to ask
you
how you feel how about you how about
your feeling to moses
you see we cannot be a muslim if you
don't believe moses
then i'm going to talk again can you do
you believe in ibrahim
they say why you will bring me further
and further and i said no i'm just
asking
if you don't believe then you have
problem because it's written in your
bible
you see so if you believe then i have
another important question
what is the name of the god of moses
what is the name of the god of ibrahim
alison
can you say that they worship jesus
because jesus came later on
are you telling me there's no god before
them
they don't believe in god you know
abraham believe in god
you know moses have god but what is the
name of the god of moses
so i'm just going to make them start to
think i want you just to reflect forever
so you see when we become a muslim we
don't lose anything
we believe in jesus we believe in the
angel we believe in moses we believe in
the torah we believe in the suffrage
we believe in everything that is the
beauty of this religion
it unites everybody
so so you also you had your experience
of being a christian also
and now so you got to to experience
buddhism christianity and over my years
of interviewing people that's what i
found i've
i found that if a person was sincere
they were gener
generally seeking the truth i mean and
they would see they would test the
man-made religions
but then when they came to islam
submission to the creator not the
creation
they would see the the connection that
their heart had to it
and it would really stand out from all
the rest
of course and what do you think is the
the main problem today what are you
seeing that
even amongst some muslims that now many
some don't appreciate you know it has to
be someone like yourself
you know somebody who had to really go
outside and
really investigate but some people take
it for granted because maybe my father
was muslim
or my my parents and but then when it
comes down to actually
submitting right uh themselves and
obeying the commands of allah their
creator they're kind of like burger king
have it your way they're kind of just
you know
uh making things up as they go have you
seen a lot of this happening
oh yeah it's happening everywhere it's
happening everywhere
i i i don't blame a lot of them
brother you know why through my humble
experience mixing around with them
the elders the copra the intellectual
the academician you know and everybody i
mix with
all group of people yeah uh
from from the the lowest of the low
to the upper of the up you know
so then i i i i start to realize you
know
what went wrong with a lot of fellow
muslim
brothers and sisters who are getting
further further away from islam
the so-called they are secular so-called
liberal there are so many
new groups here coming out if you look
carefully you realize that what went
wrong
is because of the terbia the turbine
means the islamic education
that was been given to them majority of
the one muslim are just focusing on
ritual without values
teach them to read the quran memorize
the quran without understanding so what
can the quran
benefit them you can say i memorize the
quran you know i read the quran
but now i don't believe in the quran of
course because you don't understand
the value is not there so once they have
the value that's why
the prophet saws was sent to focus on
the al-qaeda
and the value they adapt you know
that what that is how it starts how to
develop yeah the human to think like
human
don't play god and don't be like an
enemy we are no animal
either you become the lawyers of the law
or somebody all confident they claim
that i am
god like
and also both sides but islam is always
in the middle that's why the prophet
says
the best affairs is always when you are
in the middle
and allah said to us
and we created you the ummah of prophet
muhammad sallallahu as
the middle um who
bear witness to everybody
a big responsibility how do you see now
when you are growing up can you
paint a picture or we can see like the
definition
of a man uh let's say a woman
compare that when you were coming up
and then now the generation what are you
seeing like now when you have
application forms you have i don't know
if they have that malaysia now we have
male female and then over here
non-binary
are you familiar with these terms so
they where you have are you seeing a
direct
attack on the masculinity of a man
trying to make a man more like a woman a
woman
trying to make a woman like a man i mean
obviously a man is also someone who's
compassionate who's merciful who's
loving all these qualities but also
what's the definition islamic of a man a
man's man
and a woman's woman when you were coming
up and then today
yeah if you go back to the history
history repeat bra daddy
history repeat this problem of
no half man and half woman
it happened before all of us it happened
it's not something new to us
everybody is aware of at the time of
loot
and so on but then what did god
say about these people do god
acknowledge accept them and do
god say it's okay no and that's why even
in buddhism
even in christianity in judaism in all
religion
they just cannot accept
what that we are accepting today because
we are playing god today we know this
thing will happen
it's part of allah but we are not here
to promote
we are not here to endorse we are here
to help them if they need help
if not we have to leave them to allah
almighty
is sometimes this kind of thing
yeah it do not just it's not just a
virus to attack your body it attacks
your mind
your brain know and now you cannot
think straight anymore you just do not
know how to differentiate
here between hawk and battle
we know the creation starts with adam
and eve everybody who believe in the
book they must accept it
yeah there's no no other than is under
adam
and eve male and female was a kazari
other than that is a disease
whatever you want to name is up to you
you can come up with new term
but still according to the book
from the time adam was created
until the end of time the law of the
divine law will not change
allah will only recognize
the he and see and this is not something
this is not something new i mean this is
according to the teachings of jesus
jesus peace be upon him according to the
jesus
teachings of moses abraham they all
taught the same thing a pure monotheism
differentiating the role of the man and
the woman
uh you also have these are the teachings
of christianity of
judaism so this is not like uh anything
new but
what people are bringing now uh that's
something that's going against
uh what the creator has sanctioned from
all of us tell us
what do you when when we say this word
also
what do we you know uh what does that
define that word from us and how how do
we uh implement this
as men in our lives rira this term gira
and do you see this
kind of going away from from many
yet because allah almighty have warned
us about this you know the man
you see the prophet also have warned us
about their common time
you know so the the
the men have lost their identity as a
man
the woman were dressed like a man the
man dressed like a woman
they behaved just the opposite sometimes
they started with fun it's just funny
it's just an act you know
but later on it becomes an issue
you see that's why islam always said
prevention is better than cure
we know we're just like the wireless
kuwait 19 today
no how do islam introduce this
prevention
it's better than cure whatever is
affected
is a virus a disease is very very
fatal very very dangerous it can spread
very far
they cannot move from that area
total isolation and the one that
is not being affected cannot enter a
complete
yeah quarantine this is not new
not only the world health organization
come up with this
sop it was recommended by our prophet
some 1000 years ago
but a lot of this good teaching that was
guided by allah almighty who created us
who know what is the best way to solve
our problem
but we have failed ourselves because we
overconfident we thought that we know
better than god
if everybody would just come back to god
and look for his guidance
and he said follow this man because this
is the time
that nobody can be the way except
prophet muhammad sallallahu
in the time of moses moses is the way to
god in time of
jesus jesus is the way to god in the
time of prophet
until the end of time muhammad sallam
the man where the people are talking bad
about him
he is the only way
to god allah says
if you say you believe in god you love
him
you love allah just command us to follow
one man
then you gain the love from allah we
fail to follow this man allah says
you have to follow my last messenger to
you muhammad sallallahu alaihi
then i yah [ __ ] of allah i allah the
creator will love
all of us and when he loves us the first
thing he will do
he'll forgive all our students
so just uh just to conclude now uh you
see a lot of christians
and people i've interviewed
christians and one in particular who was
really fascinated
about how muslims hold firmly
to many of the divine commands that god
almighty has sent like we
we talked about the pure monotheism this
is the one thing when somebody really
looks at between the man-made religions
and then they look at the truth of the
pure monotheism this just stands out
from the rest and this is what really
brings the majority of people to islam
but then you have the the moral code
the manners and they're not swaying away
where islam is not like a buffet like
you know just do it your way
and then everything is just there it's
laid out people respect that they really
you know this christian in particular
one christian his name is owen
uh benjamin he was looking at it he said
man i i i couldn't go
find a church where i can go where it
wasn't they were
not modifying things but i really
respect the muslims because
they are really holding to those
principles you know
uh that are really that are really clear
there and for him that was just
amazing you know so we're just
continuing talking about some of these
things
and just to remind also the um the
people like you said the leaders to be
leaders
you know to invite to the dean to share
the deen and to us to really
uh be grateful for what we have uh
of the dean and tabia education so
important so what closing
comments and advice do you have now as
we conclude sheikh
yeah i think we have yeah to do our part
everybody have a duty
that's why the prophet says
everyone is a leader at least to
ourselves
said good example we are muslim
allah said only in the book
of allah the last testament quran
there is this kind of sentence allah
says
you are the best nation where the early
scripture you don't have this kind
of ayah this kind of sentence only in
islam
allah said you are the best ummah
why we are the best because we follow
what allah wants us to do and we follow
the thinking of prophet muhammad
and forbid people from doing anything
that is bad
it start from ourselves that's why the
saying of the prophet
is a very short hadith that i always
remind my student please memorize this
hadith you say you love prophet muhammad
memorize his saying and it's simple
even you brother i believe you have
remembered that very simple
finish the prophet is telling us a
muslim is a person who will not
say or do anything that will cause
harm to themselves set good example
and then you are not going to cause harm
to others
there is a muslim is a person
who are believe in what is good for him
and he will do it
show good example be kind be loving be
sincere be committed be clean
you know be honest you know be
trustworthy
all the good thing that's all the islam
want us to do and once you have done
that you can set a good example to
anybody
wherever you go and that's where the
allah says
be connected to allah wherever you are
whatever you do you are a businessman
don't
cheat don't lie be an honest yeah
businessman honestly the best policy you
know
when you are become a husband be the
best husband the prophecy
the best among men and the men who are
best to the wife example
yeah when you are a father be a good
father
take this as a mana when you are a good
leader then you become a good leader
then those who are not leaders become
good followers you see this how you go
move on move on
and this is the beauty of islam islam
have everything
from cradle to grave everything is so
detailed when you want to eat eat what
is halal what is good and how to eat
how to drink also islam is here to guide
you you want to talk you want to talk
you can talk but you
how to talk what kind of
of word you should use everything is
guided
you don't get it in any other idea
because they are not perfect yet they
are not completed yet only in islam
today i perfected my religion for you
whatever you need
in this life until they hear after
everything is there
and i have completed my favor
upon you whatever you need from cradle
to grave how to educate a person
how to eat how to drink how to behave
how to talk to your parents how to talk
to the elders how to give to the young
the neighbor and everything how to do
business
everything is there and then
allah said i choose allah use this word
i choose this religion for you
it cannot be wrong the problem is now
the people
are lost they don't know what to choose
but this religion that allah
sent to prophet muhammad he himself
choose for us
can you imagine brother eddie if the
creator the king
choose something for you how do you feel
you feel so blessed you know
and then if a guy is known number one
specialist in this he choose something
for you you feel so great now this is
the creator
who create alcohol one of us choose this
religion
for us allah it's a great blessing
it's really a great blessing thank you
so much sheikh thank you for sharing
your wisdom with us thank you for
sharing your advice jazakallah is very
nice to to have you on the program again
may i love the lord
say my warm salam to everybody to your
family
we hope you'll meet up soon again insha
allah you know
you always love to see all the good
people around us
and we love to share whatever we have
with all the good people
you know it can be anybody the christian
you have good people around them the
buddhists the
disbelievers so called this with the 80s
the free thinker
you know i have been traveling to china
before
having a lot of discussion with all the
ting tang
who are there homies but i stop to them
about religion they
they are very open alhamdulillah they
start to realize oh
because they just do not want to get
involved in any religion because they
don't have the understanding
you see they take it it's like a drop
you know make you
you know high and then forget about your
responsibility yeah people who go for
chanting and go for
meditating they become lazy after they
don't like people like that they want
people to be productive
i say that is what islam is about
it's about creative constructive
productive you just name
everything good there is in islam
thank you jesus at the end is allah will
give hidayah we will just try our best
to share whatever knowledge allah has
given us
and the best knowledge is what allah
said call allah
or call that rasool allah not what i
think
how you think but what allah said and
what the prophet salallahu
inshallah
far and wide support us on our patreon
page so we can continue this work
thank you for tuning in
subscribe right now